C'est quand même quelque chose, cet enchevêtre d'inconnu
enfermer ensemble pendant des jours qui n'ont rien en commun sauf le besoin d'aller dans un endroit à un autre
et qui ne se reverront jamais !
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH !
Je sens quelque chose de malfaisant dans ce train !
Un passager est mort !
Alors, ils n'ont fini par l'avoir !
Vous pensez il a été tué ?
Non, non, non, non, non mais euh...
Il était en excellent santé et il avait des ennemis.
En effet, il a été assassiné !
Seigneur... un meurtre ici !
Paix à son âme !
Quelqu'un est venu fouillé dans ma cabine en plein milieu de la nuit et personne n'a voulu me croire !
Si il y a eu un meurtre...
Mais que ce passe t-il ?
Alors il y a un Meurtrier
le Meurtrier est parmi nous
et chacun de vous est suspect !
Et vous ? Qui est vous ?
Je m'appelle Hercule Poirot
et je suis sans doute le plus grand détective du monde !